police in California say another mass
shooting may have been averted officers
arrested 37 year old Rodolfo Montoya
he's a cook at a Marriott in Long Beach
at his home they found several guns and
ammunition now his arrest is one of the
latest in a string of mass shooting
threats after deadly attacks in El Paso
Texas and Dayton Ohio
CBS this morning national correspondent
Jericka Duncan is here tarika how
exactly did they find Montoya well Toya
Montoya basically told a co-worker
Monday he planned to come into work and
shoot everybody he saw at the hotel
because of a so called Human Resources
issue while that co-worker
notified Long Beach police who the next
day arrested Montoya at the RV where he
lives and confiscated an arsenal of
weapons suspect Montoya had clear plans
intent and the means to carry out an act
of violence that may have resulted in a
mass casualty incident Long Beach Police
arrested disgruntled hotel cook Rodolfo
Montoya at his home in Huntington Beach
they seized multiple high-powered
firearms hundreds of rounds of
ammunition and tactical gear including
an assault rifle and high-capacity
magazines which are illegal in
California
Irma Escobedo worked with Montoya at the
Marriott hotel she says he sometimes
made her uncomfortable but she never
reported him he looked for me and he
touched me or gave me a kiss on the head
I said don't touch me please don't don't
kiss me because the cameras out of there
and I don't like that one of the
suspects neighbors who did not want to
be shown says another neighbor warned
him to stay away from Montoya one next
door told me that he had guns in that RV
and stay clear that he's got all kinds
of guns now at least 29 people have been
arrested in 18 states for threatening
mass violence since mass shootings this
month in Texas and Ohio in Orlando
Wednesday a 16 year old girl was
arrested for allegedly threatening to
shoot people in her sister's Catholic
school according to the arrest report
she said in a group text next person to
say something is the first person I will
shoot on the school shooting that will
take place this Friday
as for Montoya we reached out to
Marriott but they have not
given us a comment police would not
confirm whether Montoya was about to be
fired and that's why he was upset but
when it was brought up at a press
conference on Wednesday the hotel's
general manager nodded his head Anthony
Jericka thank you